you're an Avenger
have I killed you before
Kang has defeated Avengers before many
people do not realize how powerful this
line is right here Kang has literally
killed other Avengers before we've even
heard that there's a Thor reference an
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania with
Kang hinting that he's killed the one
with the hammer before we even know that
he who remains who we met in the Loki
finale actually collected relics of
Avengers that he's killed before we
could actually see Iron Man's helmet in
the concept art for he who remains his
room in the actual finale it's kind of
blurry so you can't really make it out
but the concept art is very clear he
collected an Iron Man helmet along with
other relics and since the kangan
quantumania and he who remains are
different variants this shows us that
multiple kangs have defeated multiple
Heroes and there's a reason for that and
that reason is Kang is pretty much
unkillable and it looks like we have
discovered a new plot point about Kang
and the MCU that makes him a way bigger
threat than we could have ever imagined
you see Kang is already in incredibly
unkillable for the most part in the
first place let's go back to Loki where
Sylvie and Loki tried to murder him and
he just kept teleporting away because he
knew their every move and even if one
Kang didn't know every move physically
fighting him is incredibly hard as well
due to his technology you see King has
been to the Future he's been to the past
and he's been to other universes and
he's taken technology that he's found
that was developed way in the future
he's able to harness Mass amounts of
energy and use it as a weapon he even
has the power of telekinesis but let's
say you somehow managed to get past all
of that and manage to get close enough
to him to actually physically fight him
one-on-one well from there he has a
shield around his body that is made out
of pure energy that is pretty impossible
to penetrate and to top it all off what
we have learned is that if you manage to
do all of that and come close to
defeating Kang you might have the
Council of Kings to deal with the
Council of Kings is exactly what it says
it's several variants of Kang coming
together to form a council now this
council is pretty bad of course it was
formed by a variant of King who was
threatened by different versions of
himself from different realities so he
forms the Council of Kings to destroy
all of the others all of the other kangs
that is ones they deem not worthy of the
name Kang but make no mistake they are a
huge threat to the Avengers because if
there is a king that they do find worthy
they will protect him this has happened
before in the comics and in some
animated versions just when the Avengers
think they've won and have defeated King
other kings show up
because even chained here stripped of my
armor I am still the Conqueror and I
will not rest until you are crushed
beneath my boot
you wish to test my might villain that
come let us
hello gang
the Council of kegs
to Avengers
we have seen them appear in various
timelines only to be eliminated
but in yours their power grows in time
left unchecked these so-called Heroes
could threaten all kangs across all of
time
the Council of Kings has sworn never to
interfere in another Kang's timeline
because of the danger posed by your
Avengers
we make an exception
with the Avengers
as we have so here's where a huge
problem in Quantum Mania can occur if
Ant-Man defeats King and Kang doesn't
even have to die most of us assume King
will live because we have King Dynasty
and Secret Wars coming up but keep in
mind there are infinite variants of Kang
and we're in the Multiverse Saga so it
doesn't have to be this particular King
we see in quantumania who is the true
variant that we'll see in these other
films and the King that we see in
quantumania doesn't seem to be at his
full King self so to speak so he's
vulnerable without his time devices and
power for them that's why he'll
originally need ant-man's help like we
hear him asking for in the trailer where
he says you'll do what I ask or your
family will suffer so he's not at his
full self in this film so what if
Ant-Man and the rest of them defeat King
what happens with the king of councils
if a king is defeated by The Avengers in
a Multiverse where it's very clear that
Kang can defeat Avengers seemingly with
e since we've already seen two different
variants have done it so if a king is
defeated it might concern the council
that a Kang variant was defeated by a
team that they have all beaten before
this presents a whole entire new problem
for The Avengers some insiders have
hinted that the Council of kings are
going to be a part of the MCU they are
going to be a thing so it is also
possible that the Kang and quantumania
is already a part of the Council of
kings that line that he states in the
trailer you're an Avenger have I killed
you before could mean that our King went
to help out other kings deal with the
Avengers in their other timelines and
make no mistake the Council of Kings
already does exist and was actually
hinted at in the season finale of Loki
most didn't know what it was at first
but now it seems very apparent that the
four statues one of them being smashed
in the foyer of he who remains base are
the Council of Kings statues dedicated
to the members of the Council of Kings
now we know that you could never really
trust a king and we know that one was
broken so this this could have been a
variant that betrayed the others by
trying to have everything himself but
these statues right here are proof that
the council does exist this means that
Kang is a way bigger threat than we
could have ever imagined you see the
closer we get to quantumania the more we
see how things are getting connected and
there are some key things that people
have either missed or forgotten about
about what he who remains told us in
Loki and for those who may not be
entirely clear about this he who remains
is King a variant of him he even says
he's been called many names and one of
them was a conqueror he came to kill the
devil right
well guess what
if you think I'm
evil well this way
see you me all right
so basically he is King the Conqueror
and here's where it gets really scary
for Ant-Man and the Avengers he who
remains stated that in the beginning
when the Multiverse was first discovered
and kangs were making contact with each
other they were peaceful at first then
eventually some Kang started to fight
each other but if the best of the best
or the worst of the worst kings teamed
up then who could stop them well what if
the not so peaceful ones got together
and formed a pack or a council to rule
over all of the universes the Multiverse
themselves they would take out anyone
who would get in their way and that
includes Kings but also Avengers you see
as you saw in the animated clip kangs
can monitor other timelines as well and
can intervene if they choose to do so so
this basically makes Kang impossible to
kill if he has allies and on top of that
in the comics one of Kang's Powers is
him being able to transfer his
Consciousness into another Kang which
basically allows him to live for forever
in fact many people think that he who
remains hinted at this in the season
finale of Loki because he tells Sylvie
as he's about to die see you soon that
could be the case but he's also probably
referring to his variants now typically
the council doesn't interfere however
they have made expectations for The
Avengers before when they fear the
Avengers will get too powerful so when
the Avengers get too strong the council
interferes they probably have already
done this in many different timelines
and Kevin feige the president of Marvel
Studios has already confirmed that we
are going to see multiple variants of
Kang in the Multiverse Saga even
confirmed that some are going to be
fighting against each other so not only
do the Avengers have to deal with one
Kang or multiple kings that are fighting
by themselves but they'll also have to
deal with the Council of Kings so Kang
isn't really just one person he's kind
of like an entity an entity that can't
really be killed so the Avengers really
can't kill him because the others will
come the only way to really kill Kang is
to kind of erase him from exist which is
what the heroes might try to do in
Avengers Secret Wars because we pretty
much know how the ending of the Kang
Dynasty is going to go Kang is going to
win it's pretty much going to be like
Infinity War where Thanos wins so the
Avengers are going to realize that they
simply just can't kill Kang to get rid
of him this is why they can't really
defeat him the only way to do this is to
erase him from existence so we'll see if
that's what is going to happen we'll see
if that's the key to Avengers Secret
Wars but in the meantime let us know
what you think about this in the
comments down below leave all your
thoughts and your theories don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up to date on the latest MCU news you
can always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf